[Musique]
je vous emmène l'île maurice on est avec
elliott fava elliott
oui oui c'est parti tester du matériel
audio aujourd'hui tous les deux ans j'ai
mon petit assistant avec moi je suis
très heureux je vous emmène qui fait une
journée magnifique ici ça c'est plutôt
cool on va parler de cette boîte la
jeune shelly merci on va parler de cette
boîte l'ars et des écouteurs ce sont du
trou ayanleh c'est assez cool
la boîte ceo z le produit cr z est un
produit intéressant
quelques jours que je teste et je vais
vous dire ce que j'en pense nous voilà
au genou line c'est vachement cool
alors si vous attendez des petits bruits
de personnes c'est qu'à côté vous avez
l'hôtel qu'en train d'être fait
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas eu dans une
précédente vidéo petit chat elliott tu
m'emmènes la boîte se blesse c'est mon
assistant boîte elliott
dès que je le fasse participer via la
boîte c'est un petit gars oui ça va tu
es heureux des vacances oui là il est
sympa pas victoire
oui oui j'ai dit oui et tu dis pas non
bon aujourd'hui on parle donc de sa
petits écouteurs plutôt cool et oz cdu
trueye en laisse
intéressant alors en fait pour moi
l'intérêt de ce produit si vous voulez
c'est que vous avez des écouteurs qui
vont être qualité haut de gamme moyen
haut de gamme de bonne facture et
surtout le truc est vraiment énorme avec
ça c'est l'autonomie vous avez jusqu'à
80 10 heures d'écouté leurs 90 heures
parce que vous avez une boîte de
recherche
je vous montre ça je t'adore la poche la
boîte ça ressemble à ça lorsque vous
l'ouvrez vous trouvez à l'écouteur jeter
la garde parce que je suis sur un petit
ponton et si tout allait très mal
vous avez travaux deux petits écouteurs
alors l'intérêt des écouteurs c'est que
ils vont venir s'intégrer directement au
tour vos oreilles c'est plutôt bien et
notamment ce que vous allez faire du
running
donc ça c'est gros point positif vous
avez donc une boîte qui en fait une
power banque vous la recharge est ici en
usb type c'est ça c'est cool boîte
pratique 5 discret ça c'est plutôt bien
l'écouteur en lui-même est plutôt simple
pareil de la même manière assez discret
vous avez bien votre petit parti marqué
right to life c'est juste là les
connectiques pour leurs charges et
sincère très facilement dans vos
oreilles
je prends ici leur ait tout fait et vous
le passez d'abord ici autour de votre
oreille là il pendouille un peu oui
vous venez vous le mettez dedans il
trouve sa position extrêmement
naturellement très facilement donc ça
c'est plutôt cool on va pas s'endetter
j'ai une groupe parti shas d'estivé du
court
j'entends connecte il dans mon oreille
donc hissé directement connecté le 2
j'ai passe autour de monorail pareil hop
il vient bloquer derrière il est là il
est posé et ses parrainages et soeurs
déjà comme ça qu'on voulait mais tu es
de base devant une espèce d'isolation
pas si donc c'est là un peut obstruer
vos oreilles donc ça c'est point plutôt
positif ça marche bien c'est pratique
qu'est ce qu'il ya lieu tu tu veux quoi
une canada il faut pas jeter dans la mer
ah ouais mais pas tout de suite sa
chérie vous avez donc des écouteurs trou
wireless
les deux sont indépendants et vous
connecter directement à votre smartphone
ça c'est bien
la collection hyper rapide en plus c'est
du bluetooth 5.0 ce qui fait que ça se
connectent extrêmement rapidement il n'y
a pas de problème de connexion ça
décroche pas ça c'est bien donc ça c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment fort
donc ça c'est le premier gros point fort
vous avez une très bonne auto lui parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'avec le bluetooth
5.0 faisait quand même une meilleure
autonomie donc là c'est le cas donc ça
gros pouce bleu donc ça c'est pas
seulement bien cette autonomie justement
pour moi cette deuxième point fort c'est
énorme vous avez quand vous les prenez
comme ça quand ils sont chargés à fond
vous avez 5,5 heures d'autonomie déjà
tout simplement comme ça donc ça c'est
vachement bien
à savoir que vous avez deux batteries de
50 milliards d'erreur une de chaque côté
forcément et surtout vous avez un
boîtier de recherche de deux mille deux
cents millions perreur qui vous donne
jusqu'à 90 horde écoute et vous le
recharger en entier très facilement en
une heure et demie en usb c'est en gros
en une heure et demie chaque parti pour
90 heures musique vous avez un petit
transdrug c'est dur à dire vous avez un
petit transducteurs pro graphène votre
tour d'oreille vous sert aussi bien le
maintien que d'antenne de communication
et en plus y'a un truc est vachement
bien c'est que dessus là en fait vous
avez un petit pavé tactile ça c'est
tactile lorsque vous appuyez dessus ça
sera un morceau suivant morceaux
précédents lecture pause et lorsque vous
appuyez longtemps ça fait on off ça les
allume sa les étapes et ce qui est bien
c'est qu'il fonctionne tout d'une
manière indépendante pourquoi parce que
c'est du trou alliant laissera blues
avait bien suivi l'histoire
en plus ce qui est vachement cool c'est
quand voulait téléphoner avec la qualité
et bien vous avez un micro de chaque
côté dont vous pouvez choisir sans
utiliser celui droite soit celui de
gauche soit les deux en même temps comme
vous voulez ça c'est pareil c'est votre
convenance ça marche bien la boîte ce
que j'aime bien c'est je trouve qu'il ya
quand même un contenu qui est premium
sont vachement bien bossé leur packaging
donc ça c'est pareil c'est gros gros
gros point positif
en plus ce truc qui est vachement bien
et ce qui est quand même assez rare
c'est que vous avez une carte de membre
à l'intérieur oddo est marquée member
karger numéro dessus c'est de vous le
montrer comme ça sans vous filer le
numéro
le qr code ni rien ou pas c'est pareil
ça permet d'avoir un côté un peu plus
premium au niveau du produit
vous avez des petits embouts en silicone
à mémoire de forme à trois tailles
différentes pour ça que dans les
oreilles de tout le monde votre charge
de beagle de ces bons c'est assez
complet c'est plutôt bien fouler le
packaging et premium et en plus de celle
d'une certification ipx si ce n'est
qu'il est résistant à l'eau l épave ou
ballet sous un ouragan mais s'il pleut
il ya pas de soucis surtout à la sueur
pour tous les sportifs et les sportifs
si vous allez courir vous avez vos
petits écouteurs il ya de la sueur c'est
pas un problème tout va bien et
rassurant contre 8 il fait une chaleur
ici on est bien c'est l'été il fait beau
il fait chaud donc si vous avez de la
sueur vous transpirez beaucourt et il y
aura absolument aucun pour les mêmes
effets que vous et subtile ça je drague
qu'une fois de plus c'est bien pour moi
c'est vraiment des produits qui vont
destinée je dirai tout un chacun pour
utilisation courante pour aller faire du
running pour aller faire du vélo pour
aller faire ce que vous voulez pour les
utiliser dans les transports en commun
ça marche bien les fidèles à cette
petite l'isolation passif c'est bien ça
va permettre d'avoir aussi une bonne
qualité en gros vous avez un produit qui
est de bonne qualité qui inquiète et
sonore qui assez bien c'est pas la
meilleure qualité qu'on puisse savoir
vous n'allez pas voir une qualité d
airpod mais vous avez quand même avoir
une qualité assez premium pour un tarif
milieu de gamme et c'est tout le
positionnement de ce produit là il ya un
très bon rapport qualité prix
et en plus ils sont rendus au tarif de
99 euros et s'il vous intéresse comme
c'est une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec et oz vous avez une
réduction de 15% plus les frais d'envoi
qui vous sont offertes vous trouverez le
lien en bas dans la description pour y
aller donc ça c'est plutôt cool vous
permet d'avoir un tarif intéressant
moi en tout cas je trouve ça bien il
faut pour les acheter et que vous aimez
ce système qui va venir déjà vous
obstrué l'oreille le côté bugs
il faut que vous aimiez le tour
d'oreille derrière mais si vous aimez ça
les produits se trouvait assez cool toi
tu veux une canne à pêche elliott mais
tu veut pêcher quoi tu sais pas pêcher
château
en fait tu mets de la musique à cause de
la nourriture et les bars quelques
mauvais choix
ouais et après yann c'est un poisson qui
mentent tirs
ouais c'est rationnel mais après tu le
pech et tu veux comme sa fin de la pêche
toi tu réfléchis pas comme poisson le
barracuda besoin
bon écoute mon chéri on verra pour la
pêche en tout cas dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez de ces écouteurs est ce
que voulait trouver intéressant oui non
pas comment un merci à mon assistant
merci mon elliott oui merci merci merci
voilà vous me dites nous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire et quant à
nous on se retrouve d'ici quelques jours
c'est la période de vacances est un peu
plus un mec cool en ce moment mais je
suis quand même dans quoi donc rassurez
vous voilà retombe ce faire une petite
baignade
on va pas aussi stricte la pêche et vie
voilà voilà fait des gros budgets